Okay, good afternoon class. So
this will be our last class before the
break. We have a three week break coming
up.
I hope that during these three weeks you
have a chance to reflect on what what
we've learned because when we come back
we'll continue build on the ideas that
we've learned so far. And so today I
want to talk about the meritocracy.
The meritocracy means that people should
succeed based on their talent, their
ability, and their hard work. And in
theory this sounds like a good idea. And
in fact, the school system is built
around the idea of a meritocracy. The
good students go to the best
universities and then after they
graduate they will get the very best
jobs.
That's the idea.
But what I will show you today is that
there are actually lots of problems
with the meritocracy and what I will
also show you is that in fact this idea
is actually destroying American society.
Okay? So the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to explain to you why
America has the world's most complicated
uh admission system.
Okay, so in China when you apply to
university you take the Gaokao, you take
you take an examination and then based
on on your test score you get into
university. And this is the system that
most countries use. Only in America is a
system that's complicated. Your
transcript matters but so does your
uh standardized test scores, the SAT,
uh the TOEFL, so does your
extracurriculars.
So does teacher recommendation letters
and so does essays in which you have to
say to America, "I'm a really good
person."
Why does it matter if you're a good
person?
Okay? So it's it's the world's most
complicated admission system. So what
I'll do first is is explain to you why
we have this system. Okay.
So we start off in England
in the 1600s.
And at this time in history in England
there's a major conflict between
um religious belief and the king, okay?
The king is head of the
Anglican Anglican Church which is the
official church of England. And there's
no difference between the Anglican
Church and the Catholic Church. The only
difference is in Catholic Church the
head is the Pope and the Anglican Church
the head is the King of England. That's
the only difference. In terms of
rituals, in terms of belief, it's the
same. Now there are people called
Protestants
who
believe there should be no Pope, there
should be no king. You should as an
individual be able to access God
directly. And you do that by reading the
Bible.
So at this time in history there's a
major conflict between the Protestants,
the the Puritans,
uh or dissenters,
and the king and it leads to wars
basically. And so the solution is the
king says to the dissenters, "Hey,
there's this new place called America.
It's far away. Go there guys and leave
me alone." Okay? So
uh the dissenters go as pilgrims
to
America to build their own theocracy,
what they believe to be the new
Jerusalem or paradise on Earth, heaven
on Earth.
Now one core belief of the Protestants
is you must read the Bible in order to
understand the mind of God. Therefore,
education, literacy, learning, it is the
divine imperative. And that's why they
established Harvard, okay?
Harvard was a school designed to train
people into the religion called
ministers
in order to study the Bible, in order to
spread the truth of the Bible.
Now Harvard then would um encourage
development of other universities, uh
Yale, Princeton, okay?
And collectively they would be known as
the Ivy League. Okay? So this is how the
Ivy League started because America was
founded as a religious colony
and everyone needed to read the Bible so
they needed places to study the Bible
and so they founded Harvard and then
Yale and then Princeton. Okay? But over
time as America became more wealthy it
became also less religious. And so the
Ivy League became social clubs.
And what I mean by that is these were
just places where the rich of America
went to become friends, okay? It was to
build cohesion, right? Remember we
discussed the idea of cohesion where you
if you commit transgression you become
more cohesive. So these guys did not
study.
They drank.
They dressed up like girls. They had
wild parties. They played football. They
took risks.
Okay? And they became good friends and
they they went on to become the leaders
of America.
As America became much more diverse,
much bigger, and much more wealthy
it recognized that it needed to educate
its population. And so it it started
state schools, okay? State schools.
What we call A&M. Okay, you may have
heard the term Texas A&M, okay? It means
Texas Agricultural and Mechanical. The
reason why was these schools were
uh built to train farmers, engineers,
and soldiers, okay? Tradespeople in
order to help grow the American economy.
Now and these this system was extremely
successful. America was able to
industrialize really really quickly and
most people went to these schools. Only
the rich would go to the Ivy League
because they were country clubs or
social clubs.
Over time America as it began to as it
began to industrialize more and more it
recognized that it needed science and
technology. So it basically copied the
best universities in Germany. And
Germany was at this at this time the
main center of science and technology in
the world. And so they built something
called research
universities.
Okay? And a couple of the first research
universities were Chicago University,
the University of Chicago, and John
Hopkins. Okay? So in the about 1900
you have this system, okay?
Um of state schools where most people
went. If you were a poor person you go
to learn a trade and then you go and get
and get a good job and make good money.
If you were you want to be a professor
or scientist you went to these research
universities.
If you were rich you went to these
social clubs called the Ivy League. And
quite honestly it was a really good
system.
And America should have stayed with this
But what happened was
who's unhappy now about the system?
These guys, right? Harvard, Yale,
Princeton because if you think about it
over time they become less and less
relevant cuz just because you're rich
doesn't mean you're smart. All the smart
people are going to to to Chicago and
John Hopkins. And so over time we can
expect Chicago and John Hopkins to
overtake the Ivy League. Okay? And
that's why Harvard decided to to
institute scholarship programs. So they
wanted more smart people into its it it
it wanted it wanted to welcome more
smart people into its campus, okay? And
this created something called the SAT.
Okay, this is the origin of the SAT. The
SAT was founded as a scholarship program
to identify the best and brightest
students from all over America so that
they could come to Harvard and help
Harvard be the best university in the
world. Okay?
Um
but now who's angry about the system?
Harvard's not happy that the best best
students are going to Chicago and John
Hopkins. So they So they created the
SAT. And now the best students are
coming to Harvard. Now who's unhappy?
The rich kids, right? Okay? The alumni,
the legacies because
before their kids just just their kids
could just go to Harvard and have a
great time. Now it's hard for them to
get in, they have to take a test, and
also they're in class with smarter
people.
Okay? So now Harvard Harvard has a
problem.
On one hand it wants the best students
in America but on the other hand it
still wants to maintain good relations
with its alumni.
So that's why it created a new system,
okay? In this new system
grades are not the only factor.
Test scores are not are not the only
factor. Now it's focused on holistic
holistic, okay? The new word is
holistic. It's basically character.
Just being smart is not good enough. You
have to be a good person. You have to be
a strong and brave and
and virtuous person, okay? So they have
a new concept called character. But this
word was created to basically keep Jews
out, okay? Cuz Jews are really smart but
Jews like to read books. So then I got
sports.
And so like that's not good. We need
people who are manly, who are strong,
who are brave. We need white people.
Okay? So they develop this holistic
system.
And that's why we have the system that
we have today, where it's not just test
scores, it's essays, it's transcript,
it's teacher recommendations, because
they want to identify the Jews and keep
them out, okay?
Today we have the system to identify
both the Jews and the Asians to keep
them out. Yes? Do it Do it even identify
for your household? Like they will ask
for your profile. Exactly. Exactly. So
all the information that they're looking
at today is to identify your ethnicity,
your
um yeah, they they want to keep they
they want to basically want to keep
Asians out of Harvard, okay? That's it
it's that simple, all right? But but
I'll explain I'll explain more as we go
along, okay?
All right.
Um so the purpose of all these changes
is to ensure that Harvard remains the
institution of power in America. Do you
does it make sense? Harvard's not
interested in academics, it's interested
in power. Therefore, it must ensure that
the people who come to Harvard are the
ones who are most likely to succeed.
And that's why it doesn't want all
Asians. It wants a mix of students,
okay? But I'll explain this later on.
Okay.
Now in this new system, there are two
key concepts. The first key concept is
the idea of secrecy.
Okay? Secrecy Secrecy just means like
I'll never tell you why I let you in or
why I didn't let you in. I don't have
to, okay?
The other is the idea of discretion.
Discretion means that
I can choose to to
let in for no reason, okay? So in China,
if you get a really high score on the
Gaokao, Peking University or Tsinghua
has to let you in.
Not Not in America. You could be the
best student in the world, they don't
care. If they don't like you, they'll
just they'll just say, "We don't want
you." Okay? They have their own
institutional reasons to let you in and
they'll never tell you.
All right? And the system was created to
ensure that Harvard is able to recruit
the best students in the world.
But what's important for us to remember
is from Harvard's perspective, best just
means the most likely to succeed,
not necessarily
the best academically oriented student,
not the smartest student, okay?
So
let let's run a thought experiment,
okay? Let's just say that you are a
Harvard admissions officer and you're
presented with four students.
Okay? You're Harvard, the best
university in the world.
Okay? And I give you four students.
And you you you can only let in one
student, okay? You tell me who you let
in, I'll tell you if you're a good
admissions officer or not, okay?
Okay, the first is
the
best math genius from China, okay?
Everyone's like, "No." All right. Second
is the best basketball player
in the world, okay? Basketball
player
in America, okay?
Okay.
The third is the best student in the
world.
And the fourth is three generations
of Harvard, okay? So your father, your
grandfather, your great-grandfather went
to Harvard. Who do you let in?
You guys know the system. Exactly, okay?
You don't even think about it. Like I'd
let in number four, okay?
Because you know that in the world
he is the most likely to succeed. You're
not interested in educating smart
people, all you want to do is graduate
rich people.
Okay? So let's let's just say this guy
doesn't exist. Then who do who do you
let in?
Exactly. Yep, this guy, okay? Definitely
not this guy, okay? Definitely not the
math genius from China, because you know
that he's probably just going to end up
as a math teacher.
Right? Math professor, who We don't want
that. Okay? We don't want professors, we
don't want lawyers, we don't want
doctors. We want people who will be head
of a company. We want people who will
become a famous rock star. We want
people who will become president of the
United States. That's what we want,
okay?
And um
yeah, so either one of these two is
fine.
No, no, okay? But we want these guys to
apply because that helps us look better,
right? We want people to apply so we can
reject them so that our metrics
look better, okay? Okay? That Does that
make sense? Okay, that's how the system
works.
All right.
So
let me explain why they do this, okay?
Why is this system system set like this?
The best analogy for Harvard, Yale, and
uh sorry, go go ahead.
Uh like does all the admission officers
in American college
doing this intentionally?
Okay, that's a really good question,
okay? So um if you're the Ivy League,
you do this because everyone wants to go
to the Ivy League. But if you're an
average school, you're actually just
trying to recruit students, okay? So so
this this is like the school This is a
mentality of admissions officers for
elite schools. But most most schools are
just like they want you to come in and
pay the tuition, okay?
So why uh the Yale pick you?
Yeah, I'll explain later on, okay? Okay.
All right. So so Harvard
is first and foremost a venture capital
firm, okay?
Okay, you're an investment firm. So
let's let's pretend you're a venture
capitalist and I give you two options,
okay?
And you tell me which option you pick.
Option one is
I want to open a restaurant.
And I need a million dollars from you.
Okay?
But guess what, guys?
My uncle works for the government.
So I can guarantee that he and his
friends will come to my restaurant every
single day.
And so there's no risk.
There's actually no risk involved. I
guarantee it will make at least
$500,000
a year. No risk,
easy money, okay?
Number two is
I want to start a website
that that's AI and Bitcoin or what and
uh
um all all all this, okay?
Problem is
I don't even know how to write code. I
have no experience
writing doing a website.
And my idea isn't really fleshed out.
But if it works, we can make one billion
dollars, guys, okay?
So
option one is low risk, really good
plan, solid returns, five $500,000 a
year, okay? Option two is
concept, vague idea, I have absolutely
no experience doing any of this, but I
but we could possibly make a billion
dollars, okay? Which option do you take?
Okay, you always take this guy's, okay?
Right? Cuz like you don't need $500,000.
That's boring. You want a billion
dollars. And that's the mentality of
Harvard. You understand?
They want to take a risk on you. They
don't want
students who are solid and who will
become a professor. That's boring, okay?
They want crazy people
who will change the world because that
makes Harvard look good. Okay, now what
I'm saying this is
they rather So so
they rather have a class
where 10 people succeed and 999 fail
rather than a thousand people succeed
slightly. Does that make sense?
Okay? Why? Because we only remember the
10 people who succeed.
We forget everyone else.
Okay?
That's the Harvard mentality.
And that's why they're the most famous
university in the world, because they're
looking to create as much
brand name recognition for themselves as
possible.
Okay?
All right.
Does that make sense?
Now
how do we know if they succeed or not
if you're Harvard?
Well, remember the concept we learned
last class, which is dissociative
personality
disorder.
And what we discussed last class is
in the game
people who are most likely to succeed
have this characteristic.
Okay? And so
I'll explain why using myself as an
example, because I got into Yale, okay?
So what we're going to do is this.
We're going to examine my application to
Yale.
And then we're going to look at how the
admission officers would perceive
application
and how they would judge my potential,
okay? So three things. The first is
what my application
actually says.
Second is they will examine my
background.
The third is they will then judge my
potential.
Okay? All right, so my application. All
right, so
I went to a public high school.
It was good, but it's not a private high
school. You get a better education at a
private high school. Plus it's it's in
Canada, okay? Which is like everyone's
kind of stupid in in Canada, okay?
So and I was like top 10 of 200 kids. So
it's good, but it's not number one, it's
not number two, it's just top 10, okay?
I was number 10.
My SAT was 1400
out of 1600. And it's like decent, but
you know, people in China can
1550, 1500 easily, okay? So,
um not not that great. I was on a soccer
team.
I was not athletic. The soccer team just
needed players, so I signed up, okay?
Um I was also editor
of a school newspaper.
Okay? And I was captain of a quiz team.
Quiz team.
Called Reach for the Top.
Okay?
So, that's a Canadian thing. But, I was
captain of it. I organized it, okay? So,
these two activities, they're fine, but
it doesn't really demonstrate leadership
potential, right? You're not like head
of student government, or you're not
head of Model United Nations.
All right?
Um on my essay, I wrote about Richard
Feynman,
who is a physicist.
It was a really boring essay.
It was
I mean, like anyone could have written
it. I mean, like Chat
Chat GPT could have written it, okay?
It's just a bad essay.
My teachers, I mean, they liked me, but
they really didn't like me because I
seemed aggressive to them, you know? I I
wanted grades too much. So, the word
they use is ambitious.
They feel I I was ambitious. Ambitious
is a dirty word in Canada. It means you
don't play by the rules. It means you're
too aggressive. It means you're too
pushy, okay?
All right? So, this is my application to
Yale. As you can see,
it is a
decent,
but
not a stellar application.
So, how did I get in?
Well, because there was some information
that they could also derive from
application that made them interested in
me, okay? The first is that I was poor.
So, I couldn't even afford the
application fee.
I had to
um apply for a waiver for my my
application, sorry.
For for for my um
application, okay?
So, I was poor because I was an
immigrant. So, I was born in China in
1976,
and my family went over when I was 1980
in 1983 when I was like six.
Okay? So, I was a poor immigrant in
Canada.
I transferred high school. So, I was I
was I was in a poor high school,
then I went to a rich high school. Okay?
So, basically I switched neighborhoods.
My family lived in a poor neighborhood,
and then I applied to go to rich high
school in a different neighborhood. So,
I I had to take the subway there every
day, and I spent like half an hour on
the subway. And guess what, guys?
Canadians don't like that, okay?
Canadians want you to stay where you
are, and that's it. So, when I told my
high school principal that I I was going
to transfer
um
high schools, he got very upset. And he
said that I'm going to write a
discipline letter, okay? A discipline
letter. And it's a very serious thing.
And I'm going to put it in your folder
so that when you apply to university,
they will know that you were suspended
from the school.
And And like that that's basically like
a really bad thing, okay?
Um so,
um I got a a dis- discipline letter. And
when when I went to the rich high
school,
I had no friends. Why? Because
they didn't like me. Because they don't
like it when someone new comes in.
Okay? I didn't know their culture. I I'm
sort of like ambitious, and I was grade
grubbing grade grubbing. But, the thing
is I was desperate because my family was
very poor, and I wanted a better life,
okay?
Okay?
So,
again, they all they know all this,
okay? They know I'm a average student,
and they know that I'm pushy and
ambitious.
And
that's why Yale let me in. Because it's
clear from this information that I had
dissociative personality disorder.
Okay? What What does that mean?
It means, first of all, I'm desperate.
Okay?
Desperate means like if I don't get into
Yale, I'll probably kill myself. I I
mean, if I didn't get into Yale, I would
drown. I couldn't breathe. It was a life
life or death issue for me. They can see
the desperation. They want that, okay?
Second thing is
I was insecure.
Okay? If you're an insecure person, it
means you're not happy with who you are.
It means there's a void in your heart.
And therefore, the way to fill the
insecurity is through achievement.
Okay?
So, if I make a million dollars,
I won't be happy. I will need need to go
make two million dollars.
If I made 10 million dollars, I would
see people around me who had 100 million
dollars. And I would be like, I need I
need to go make a billion dollars, okay?
So, an insecure person
sees the world as a competition.
And
um
you're always
achieving and achieving, okay? And
that's how you succeed, okay?
And the third thing is
I was not a moral person, okay? I was
ready to break the rules in order to
succeed, transgressive. Okay? So, I was
not supposed to leave my poor high
school and go to rich high school.
That's breaking the rules in Canada.
It's not illegal, but you're not
supposed to do that. And I didn't care.
The principal said I couldn't do that. I
said to him, "Screw off. I'm still going
to do it."
I went to the rich high school. Everyone
said to me, "You're not welcome." I
said, "I don't care. I'm I'm going to
get my good grades, and I'm I'm going to
get into the Ivy League. I don't need
you guys, okay?" So, they saw the
desperation. They saw the insecurity.
They saw the hunger and the amorality.
And this is pa- all part of dissociative
personality disorder. And that's why
they let me in. Because it's possible I
go crazy, okay? It's po- it's possible I
become depressed, but it's also possible
I change the world.
Okay? Does that make sense? That's how
they think. Because they're a venture
capital firm. They're looking for the
riskiest investment with the best
possible return.
They're looking for people who can
become president of the United States,
who can change the world, who can make a
name for themselves. Because if they do
that, that makes Yale look good. So, you
remember the name, okay? It's all about
brand name recognition.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
Okay. So, you're like, "Okay, well, this
is fine,
but and what's wrong with the system,
okay? Why would this be a bad thing? It
works. Why would Why would this be a bad
thing?"
Well, the problem with this is
because Yale, Harvard, and Princeton are
so powerful, not only are they looking
for
people with trauma, okay? I was
traumatized as a child, but they're also
traumatizing the world.
Okay? If that makes sense.
All right? So, the meritocracy
um exists to find people with trauma,
and because it exists, it's traumatizing
the world. Okay? So, let me explain how
and why.
Any questions so far?
Is this all clear? Yeah?
Um so, unless if like the a Harvard and
Princeton are these college students,
then why
why they're still like so famous?
Because um this system is um
is is just unreasonable for and and
unequal for the students who have great
who uh who who who have a good grades.
Okay. All right. That's a really good
question, okay? So, why are Harvard
students or Yale students, Princeton
students so famous? Okay. The reason why
is when you do investment, you don't
take you you don't do all risky
investments, okay? You always have You
always have diversity in your portfolio.
So, the majority of students are still
students who will be successful no
matter what. Why? Because their families
are rich.
Okay? So, if you're So, if we go back to
the example, right? Those four, you let
in the child who had who's comes from
three generations of Harvard graduates,
okay? And that's the majority who of
people who get into Harvard. And then
you let in the athlete, okay? So, the
athlete, the legacy, these are the
people who are the majority. Those are
the safe investments. And then you have
like 1%
of positions for people like me who you
like you don't really know, but there's
potential there, so let's take a risk.
Okay? And quite honestly, it's a
crapshoot because
um it's all very discretionary. So, they
basically it's all intuition, okay? They
don't have a formula for this. They just
think, "This guy is interesting. Let's
just let him in, okay?" And it's
possible you on an essay, you just wrote
something really interesting, and they
laugh, and they're like, "Okay, let's
let's take a chance on this guy." They
have that 1%
of of positions available for risk,
okay? Does that make sense? Okay? So,
I'm not the average Yale student. I'm
I'm I'm I'm a marginalized Yale student.
Okay?
So,
um
this system, the meritocracy, the way
it's set up, it creates trauma.
Okay? So, let me explain why. So, let's
look at university, Yale.
Then we'll look at high school.
Okay? Then we'll look at parenting.
Okay? So,
you think, "Oh, you get into Yale, you
can just coast. You're happy.
Life is simple." Okay? The fact of the
matter is that when you get into Yale,
Yale is actually The Hunger Games.
Have you read the book The Hunger The
Hunger Games?
It is a relentless competition.
Because once you're in Yale, you're
still competing. But now you you're
competing against the most competitive
people in the world, okay? So maybe at
the school, you could be the best
student. Your parents love you.
You have lots of good friends. You had
student government. You feel really good
about yourself.
You go to Yale and then you recognize
that you're a nobody. Your parents are
far away.
And you're now in competition with the
best students from all around the world
who all want to kill you because it's a
zero-sum game, okay? Only the strongest
survive.
And so everywhere you go, it's a
competition. In the classroom, um it's a
seminar style, so you're with 20 other
students and the professor's asking you
questions and you're all competing to
impress the professor.
Okay?
Outside the classroom, you're competing
to get into clubs and something called
secret societies.
Okay? But you're also competing for
graduate school, for law school, for
medical school, for scholarships like
the world scholarship, okay? So Yale it
sounds nice, but once you get in there,
from the first day, it's an endless
pursuit of achievement. It's just
competition after competition after
competition. Wherever you go, you're
being judged by someone, okay? You're
being judged by the professor or your
classmates. And everyone's looking to
like basically
kill each other because it's a it's a
it's a winner-take-all system, okay?
So this is very traumatic. And it makes
you so insecure
that you go through life thinking
thinking like life is just like that.
Everyone's an enemy. I have to achieve
and achieve in order to feel good about
myself.
I cannot stop working hard, otherwise
I will be killed by other people, okay?
So people who graduate from Yale have a
deep sense of insecurity. Even those who
come from the wealthiest families.
Okay? They all They're always looking to
achieve. And that's what Yale wants.
That's what Harvard wants because these
are the people who will be more
successful in life, okay? They're not
happy with one $1 million, they want a
billion dollars.
Once they have the billion dollars, they
want 10 billion dollars, okay? It never
stops.
Okay? So to get into Yale, you have to
go through high school.
And high school
has to train you for Yale. So it's also
a competition, also a Hunger Games.
Okay?
And to train you for high school, the
your parents have developed a
different parenting system, okay? So
I'll give you two examples of parenting,
okay? The first system, which is the
healthy system, you say to your child,
"I love you unconditionally. No matter
what you do, I will support you. I will
always be here for you." And if you say
that to your child every day, your child
will be happy, fulfilled,
and um secure in life. But the person
will probably end up as a teacher, okay?
Now, you can also say to your child,
"I don't have time for you,
but if you win the swimming competition
or you place first on
uh your math test
or if the teacher say nice things about
you, I'll take you for ice cream."
Okay?
And so it's a system that neglects
the child while at the same time demands
the child, okay? And this is trauma.
And again,
most kids will be traumatized by this
system. But there are some kids who will
thrive in this system and the trauma
will encourage them or drive them to
achieve and achieve and achieve so that
they get into Yale so they can compete
the Hunger Games so they can go on in
life and
compete some more, okay?
And that's how the system is set up. And
this is what we call the meritocracy.
And
as I'll explain to you later on, it is
destroying America and the world.
All right? So that's how the system is
set up.
And guess what, guys? Is it different in
China?
Not really, okay?
All right? So the concept of the
meritocracy has conquered the world. It
started in America. It actually started
at Harvard, but now it's conquered the
entire world and that's why the world is
so messed up.
Um so as you say, the uh Yale gives you
so many uh negative emotions. So would
you still go there if you got a second
chance?
Okay. So that's a really good question.
Um would I go there if I had a second
chance?
And the answer is probably, okay? And
the reason why is the system system is
set up that you don't really have a
choice, right? If you want to move ahead
in the world and you're poor,
what are your options?
Right? So before in America,
um there were opportunities
for poor people to succeed. So for
example, George Washington, the first
president of the United States, he never
went to college. Abraham Lincoln didn't
go to Ivy League. And these are two I
consider the two greatest presidents in
American history.
Unfortunately today, if you look at the
presidents, if you look at the top
people, they all went to the elite
schools, okay? So the system is set up
so that if you if you want to succeed,
you have to go through the Ivy League.
But I do not plan to send my kids to the
Ivy League, okay? The last thing I would
do is have them in such a competitive,
traumatic environment as the Ivy League,
okay? Does that make sense? All right.
All right. Any more questions? So So
thank you for your question. Any more
questions before I move on?
Okay.
So let's do a PPT and I'll explain to
you how
America
is destroying
the world, okay? Sorry about this. Okay.
So I I I actually need to go back to the
beginning.
Okay. Death by meritocracy. All right.
So
let's go. Okay.
So if you from this
um graph, what you can see is this. In
the year 1875,
the best universities in the world were
actually not in America. They were in
Germany. Germany was producing the most
Nobel Prize winners.
Second was France followed by
the UK, okay? And America was
non-existent.
But because of its investments in
research universities, it started to
move up and up. And then it it won World
War II, so now it can import all these
German scientists and that's why it
dominates today. So the best
universities in the world are now
America. Or in America, Harvard, Yale,
and Princeton.
Okay?
Um now, as these universities get better
and better, they're letting more
students, okay? And as you can see,
more and more American students
are now going to college. Before in
1940,
it was only about 5% of all males who
went to university.
Today, it's almost
um it's 35% basically, okay? So that's a
huge step. And you would think that with
the increase
in um college graduates, America would
become a much more equal society, right?
Well, the opposite has happened, okay?
Um America has become a much more
unequal society.
Um there's something called the Gini
coefficient, which measures inequality.
And as you can see, um these past 20
years, it's gone way up. It's among the
highest in the world, meaning America
right now is one of the most unequal
societies in the world, even though it
it even though um over a third of its
young people go and graduate from
college.
This is a graph of social mobility,
okay? So uh the graph the top the top
this number shows you um if the number
of people who are doing better than
their parents. As you can see in the in
the 1940,
most people are doing better than their
parents. But over time,
it's no one's doing better than their
parents, okay?
So your generation,
um you will not do better than your
parents, most of you, okay?
Um
in in income inequality has gone way up
in the United States. The top 1% control
most of the wealth in the United States
as you can see from this map, okay?
So even though America has become
wealthier, it's actually going to to
just the 1%.
At the same time, univers- universities
are becoming much more expensive, okay?
So and this is leading to student debt.
And you can see how student debt,
student loans has gone way up. So in
America, student loan student debt is
the only type of debt that you can never
ever get rid of. You can't declare
bankruptcy. You can This debt cannot be
be gotten rid of, okay? When you die, it
passes on to your children, okay? So um
this is a terrible situation for young
people in
America.
This is actually more stark graph where
tuition has gone way up, but wages have
stayed pretty stagnant.
Okay?
Um and it's leading to depression among
teenagers.
Okay? And
um
also, the thing about this graph is
the middle class and wealthy students
are much more likely to be depressed and
identify as depressed than poor
students.
All right? So this is leading to a
crisis in America. So why are we Why Why
What has happened? Well, you had two
individuals who created the meritocracy.
The first is named James B. Conant. He
was president of Harvard for a couple
decades and he was a person who brought
brought in the SAT
in order to identify scholarship
students. And he made Harvard into the
best research university in America.
Okay? And he was determined to make
Harvard into the best university in the
world, as well as institution of power
in America, meaning that it would now
decide who wins and who loses in
America.
The man who would help him is named
Harry Chauncey. He was Dean of Harvard
who was in charge of the scholarship
program.
Then he got a new job at a new new
organization new organization called
ETS. You know ETS because it's education
testing services. They're the ones
responsible for the SAT, the TOEFL, the
AP, the GRE, okay?
So, these two together create the modern
meritocracy. And as you can imagine,
because they're both from Harvard, the
entire system is set up to benefit
Harvard. Okay? And guess what, guys? It
worked, okay? So, in the year 1940,
9% of applicants to Harvard got
accepted. Now, it's gone way down to
5%, okay?
Stanford is even lower, okay?
So, now it's so hard to get into
Harvard. At the same time,
look at the cash of Harvard, okay? This
is called the endowment. The amount of
money they have at Harvard is
ridiculous. They have more money than
most countries in the world. Right now,
their endowment is about $40 billion.
Dollars.
Okay? And this is just the past 30, 40
years.
The success of the Harvard alumni is
just incredible. The most billionaires
in America,
Harvard graduates more billionaires than
any other place, okay? 127 uh
billionaires in 2024. Second is
Stanford.
All right? No one else comes close.
But not only that, but it's also
anyone with of with over $100 million,
most of them graduate from Harvard,
okay? 7% of all Sorry. 7%
of all people in America who have over
$100 million in net worth graduate from
Harvard, okay? Then you have MIT,
Stanford, Pennsylvania, Columbia, Yale,
Cornell, Princeton. Guess what, guys? I
have a link plus MIT.
Okay?
Okay.
$30 million,
still Harvard is number one, okay?
All right? So, their graduates are the
most successful in America.
Okay? But it's not just rich people,
it's everyone in the American elite.
Okay? Most of them are graduates of the
elite universities. Okay? So, this is a
article in nature, and they looked at
all the elite in America. And what they
discovered is they all most of them went
to certain schools, the elite
universities. Um and this is what's
causing a lot of political conflict in
America today. All right? So, let's just
look at what they found. The red is
Harvard graduates.
Okay? The green are Harvard plus Ivy
League.
And as you can see,
Harvard is everywhere, even among
generals, admirals,
there's Harvard people.
Okay? They dominate in terms of
philosophers and professors.
But they're everywhere, even Pulitzer
Prize winners, billionaires, New York
Times best-selling authors.
Fortune 500 CEOs, federal judges,
senators, okay? They're everywhere.
And that's the power of Harvard.
This is a This is a portion of of
Harvard graduates compared with the
general population. This is the portion
of Harvard graduates compared with the
elite.
Okay?
You see You see the contrast.
So, Harvard and Ivy League dominate
America today.
Now, what's amazing is
Harvard people don't know they dominate
Harvard. They don't know they're elite.
So, they did a survey, and so they asked
people in these elite organizations,
"How many people do you think in this
organization went to Harvard and other
elite universities?" So, the red is the
actual number, the blue is the estimate.
So, Harvard and Ivy League don't even
know they dominate America.
Okay? And if you ask them, like, "No,
it's conspiracy theory.
No, you're spreading conspiracy
theories. We're just average people.
There's no way Harvard controls
America."
All right?
Now, um as I mentioned, at Harvard, just
going to Harvard is not enough. You have
to join the elite social clubs, the
secret societies. So, at Harvard,
there's a place called like the at
Harvard, everyone should join the
Porcelain Club, okay?
Um at
Princeton, it's the Ivy Club. Okay?
These are secret societies. Oh, they're
not really secret, but they're senior
they're senior societies, okay? They're
clubs that everyone should join. At
Yale, it's Skull and Bones. Okay? Skull
and Bones is the most famous college
secret society. They're not that secret
because they they like to brag that that
they're um
um Skull and Bones. They're so powerful
that they produce a lot of presidents, a
lot of rich people, okay?
20 2004, okay?
Um George W. Bush versus John Kerry.
Guess what, guys?
John Kerry is the Democratic nominee,
George Bush is the Republican nominee,
right? They're both Skull and Bones.
They're both Yale Skull and Bones.
Okay? So, it's a rigged game.
Barack Obama, okay? Barack Obama,
Columbia, went to Harvard Law School,
but he promised hope and change. He told
people in 2008 that the game is rigged
against them.
That he'll be their champion.
That he would make America more fair.
Okay? And he won. Why? Because
Well, I sorry I So, this is this is his
book, Dreams from My Father.
Um it was a New York Times bestseller.
It it basically launched his political
career.
Um he won because in 2008, the US
economy collapsed. Why? Because
the US banks, the US political system
was controlled by Ivy League graduates,
by just
people who were friends with each other.
And so, they cheated. They became
corrupt.
Okay? They basically destroyed the
American economy.
And people protested
uh against all this. And Barack Obama
promised that he would come in and do
something about it. Okay?
Well, he did he did do something about
it. All right? So, his economic team, he
appointed a quite a few individuals.
These these these are the two most
famous. Larry Summers, who was a Harvard
graduate as well as a as a president of
Harvard. And he was Treasury Secretary
under Bill Clinton, and he was the guy
who created the mess in the first place.
And then Tim Geithner, who was a
Dartmouth graduate, and he was the
Treasury Secretary, okay?
So, these are friends of Wall Street who
came in
to save Wall Street.
So, a lot of critics say, you know, it's
Wall Street who created this mess, who
destroyed the American economy. They
should be punished, or at least they
should feel some pain.
If you just let them
go and help them out and save them, then
you create a problem called moral
hazard. The idea of moral hazard is
if you don't have any have any
consequences for your mistake, you will
do it again.
Okay? And then Larry Summers said, "No,
no, you guys are seeing it incorrectly.
We have to save the American economy.
The goal is not to save the banks and my
friend. The goal is to save the American
people and the American economy, and
that's why we're bailing out the banks
by giving them
free money."
Okay? And then the critics were like,
"Well, how about all these American
homeowners who lost their homes?
Shouldn't we help them as well?"
And do you And do you know what Larry
Summers said?
"Moral hazard, guys.
Do you understand? Moral hazard. If we
help out these ordinary Americans, they
won't learn anything."
Okay?
So,
as you can see, people were angry. The
banks got saved, the people got screwed
over.
And guess what, guys? Because because of
this,
who Who did we get?
This guy.
Okay? This is what he wanted.
There were millions of Americans who who
voted for Barack Obama because he
promised hope and change.
And then they voted for Donald Trump
because he promised to destroy the
system.
Okay?
That's why we have Donald Trump.
Now,
funny story about Donald Trump and
Barack Obama. So, Barack Obama and
Donald Trump were always adversaries. In
fact, Donald Trump led a movement uh
which accused Barack Obama of not being
being born in America. Um it's He's born
in America, but Donald Trump was saying,
"No, no, he he was actually born in
Nigeria." He's saying his father is from
Nigeria.
So, Barack Obama made fun of Donald
Trump. 2011, there's a big dinner, the
White House Correspondents Dinner, where
where Barack Obama gets on gets on stage
and makes fun of Donald Trump, okay? He
says, "Hey, if Donald Trump ever became
president, this is what the White White
House would look like. It'd be a
casino." Okay?
And this is funny, right?
Donald Trump was in the audience that
day.
And everyone was laughing at him.
And that's what motivated Donald Trump
to become president of the United
States.
Okay? So, thank Obama for Donald Trump.
Without Obama, there would be no Donald
Trump.
Okay?
So, it's not just Don- Barack Obama,
it's a lot of people in the American
political class.
They're just soulless
um robots, okay? This This This man is
J.D. Vance. He's a vice president for
Donald Trump.
Like like Barack Obama, he wrote a book,
a really a best seller called Hillbilly
Elegy, and it's possible he becomes
president of the United States as well.
Now, you may not know this, but
when he first came into prominence, he
opposed Donald Trump. He thought that
Donald Trump would be a fascist and be a
dictator and all that. And then suddenly
he changes his opinion and says, "Donald
Trump is the greatest guy in the world."
Okay? So, these guys, like J.D. Vance
and Barack Obama, they have no ideas of
their own. They're just puppets. They
They just
um tell people what they want to hear.
All they know is achievement, okay? So,
a another example of this This man's
name is Johnny Kim. Okay?
And he'll probably run for president of
the United States one day or at least be
a U.S. senator.
Why Why do I mention him? Guess what,
guys?
He was a Navy SEAL.
Which is the Which is the top position
you can ever achieve in the military. He
was He was a secret soldier, okay?
He was He went to Harvard Medical
School, making him a doctor.
Then he joined NASA, making him an
astronaut.
This is like the ideal
Ivy League graduate, okay? This is what
Harvard wants.
Now, why is he able to do all this?
Well, because
this is his Wikipedia entry, okay?
In 2002, the police went into his house
and killed his father. He was there and
he saw the police kill his father. He
was traumatized for life.
His father was a domestic abuser. The
father was violent, crazy, hit him all
the time.
Okay? So, he has dissociative
personality disorder.
And in fact, if you look at most of the
of these really successful people, they
do have dissociative personality
disorder.
And that's why he was able to do all
that do all this because he's turned the
trauma into an energy to drive him to
greater and greater achievement. The
problem though is he has no ideas of his
own. He's just a puppet, guys, okay? So,
let's conclude and summarize
why the meritocracy is so great. Um it
creates this extreme inequality in
America, okay? So,
um it destroyed the school system
because all people care about are their
grades now, right? People don't even
care about learning anymore. All they
All they want are the grades. In fact,
if you get a bad grade, you'll probably
complain to teacher.
In which case the teacher is now afraid
to teach you because if the teacher
tries to challenge you make you a better
student, you'll just complain. Okay? And
you And if you don't If you don't
succeed, your parents will come and
complain, okay?
Uh traumatized children, okay? Okay?
If you look at the rate of mental
illness in China and in America, it's
just insane.
Death of American dream and social
mobility.
You're not going to be richer than your
parents. You're just not.
Uh concentration of wealth, power, and
status in the 1%. The rich The richest
just get richer. Political divide
between left and right, okay? So, you
have all this political division right
now in America.
Corruption. So, Wall Street just steals
and steals and steals and nobody do
anything about it. Destruction of
American identity, globalization,
immigration, woke ideology.
Okay? Uh incompetent mismanagement. You
look at COVID rate. You look at the fact
that America now has $37 trillion in
debt.
An elite that is soulless, mediocre, and
unimaginative, okay? Barack Obama, J.D.
Vance, this guy Johnny Kim, okay?
They're just They're just robots.
Oh, and Donald Trump.
Okay? So, thank you, American
meritocracy,
for
destroying the world.
Okay?
All right, questions, guys.
I I know this is a lot to take in,
but do you have any questions?
You're all depressed
and sad
and shocked.
Yep, we have a question.
Thank you.
Like is there a way to get rid of all
those bad
uh
impacts of this?
I mean like is there
some suggestions for us to
help us better develop ourselves uh not
just using the system? Okay.
Great question, okay? So,
the real solution is to destroy the Ivy
League.
Okay?
And there are different ways you can you
can destroy the Ivy League. The best way
is to make them public, okay? To make to
to have the for the government to come
in and control them.
Because all of the issues stem from the
fact that these are institutions that
only care about their own power.
Okay? So, the government were in charge,
um
they won't be so powerful and secretive,
okay? So, that's the best solution. It's
not going to happen because Harvard, as
you can see, is too powerful
as well as Yale.
So,
um as an individual,
your
best option is to recognize how evil the
system is
and choose to
learn for yourself, okay? Because when
you go to Yale or Harvard or Princeton,
you think you're learning, but you're
not. You're being indoctrinated and
being brainwashed and being traumatized
to be turned into basically a robot
that's only focused on success.
So, you need to recognize this, be true
to yourself, and focus on real learning.
Okay? So, what do I mean by that?
Okay.
So, let me um Sorry, let let me um
explain.
Okay. So, success.
What is real success?
Well, before the meritocracy,
you didn't have to go to college, but
you you need to have certain values
and attitude.
Okay? So, the first was to be
open-minded.
What And so,
recognize that you have a lot to learn.
And ask questions. Learn from other
people, okay?
And what people recognized was failure
is the best
teacher.
Why? Because failure forces reflection,
right?
And
resilience,
which leads to learning.
Okay? And this is the model that most
people understood before the
meritocracy. Keep an open mind, make
mistakes because if you make mistakes,
you will learn from them naturally. And
then you can reflect, and then you can
be become resilient, and then you will
grow and grow, and then you will achieve
your true potential.
Okay? The meritocracy has destroyed this
system.
Why?
Because now we just want to focus on
grades.
Okay?
And to get good grades, you cannot fail.
Do you understand? Failure now
is a problem.
If you fail a class,
you may learn a lot from your failure,
but it won't look good on good on your
GPA, right? It will destroy your GPA.
And you won't get into Harvard, okay?
You know You know how failure, you
cannot have reflection, you cannot have
resilience. Also,
before you had time for yourself.
Nowadays, every minute
is organized for you, right? You come to
school, the school day is very long,
then you have lots of homework,
and then you have activities,
then you have to have dinner, then all
that. You don't have any You don't even
have time to just think for yourself, to
just chill and do what you want to do,
okay? It's intentional.
Okay? So, it's destroying reflection,
you don't have any resilience,
and so you can't learn anything.
So,
the So, it's a really
bad system because if you're like me,
okay? You're just a normal person, your
family your family's not rich or
powerful, and you go to Yale and
Harvard, it actually makes you fail in
life, okay? Let me explain why.
Okay? The first is
it makes you arrogant.
It makes It makes you It makes you
think, "I went to Yale, therefore I know
more than anyone else, so I don't have
to ask questions. I don't have to learn
anymore, okay?"
Um second is that it makes you you you
utilitarian.
You only care about things that help you
succeed. You're not actually interested
in real learning anymore.
Okay? And the third thing is
all you care
about is success, so you're
narrow-minded.
You don't want to explore, okay? You're
not so creative anymore.
Okay?
So, it's it's a great system if you come
from a rich family because this system
trains you to to go into power. But if
you're just like me and you need to work
hard and be talented
uh and be committed to your passion in
order to succeed, this actually destroys
all that. And that's why
um probably most traumatized people in
America are those who came from poor
families, who had a dream of going to
Ivy League, who got into Ivy League,
and then
they just fell in life because they
don't have the
ability to succeed. They don't have the
reflective ability. They don't They
don't have the resilience. They're not
open-minded. They don't accept failure.
They're not committed to learning.
They're only committed to success.
Okay? So, if you're rich, go to Harvard
and Yale and Princeton cuz you'll become
more rich. But if you're a poor person,
going to these schools may be a mistake.
Okay? Certainly for me
um it was a mistake because after I
graduated, I stumbled through life.
Uh for me it was just failure after
failure after failure because I want to
succeed right away.
Okay? I refused to put the time and
effort to learning a real skill
and learning a real passion.
Um and so um in my 30s, late 20s, early
30s, I became really depressed.
And honestly, I thought about killing
myself and um
I was playing video games every single
day. I just hid in my parents' basement.
And so
um I was traumatized by Yale. It took me
a long time to get over the trauma and
recognize this is a false system.
Okay? Yale traumatized me and I need to
relearn to be open-minded, to embrace
failure,
to be resilient, to embrace learning,
okay? And that's why I'm a teacher
today, to teach you guys that to be
successful in life, this is the formula,
okay? You don't need Harvard, Yale, and
Princeton.
All right?
All right? Any more questions, guys?
Yep.
Well, um can we do both, like
open-minded and get the grades and being
rich? Okay. Is it a possible thing?
>> Yeah, that's a great question. Thank
you, okay? All right.
Okay. So, I'm going to I'm going to have
to go into some psychology here, okay?
But psychology have have discovered that
we have two modes of being. Okay?
There's the altruistic
mode
and there's the utilitarian mode.
Okay?
Okay? So, utilitarian is what we call
fight
or flight.
Okay?
Uh altruistic is just family and
connections.
So, imagine we're back in the village,
okay?
And most of the time we are
Yeah, yeah?
Like you
but you said that all the psychology is
just brainwashing. Okay. I I'm Yes,
psychology is not all brainwashing.
There's some validity to it, okay?
And so, I'm not saying this is suddenly
fact, I'm just saying this is a good way
to understand
how things work, okay? All right? All
right. So, you So, in the village, we
spend most of time
being close with other people, right? We
want to be friends with other people, so
we help each other out.
But sometimes
um
we have to be very u- utilitarian. So,
for example, um if there's no If there's
If there's not enough food, okay?
Or we're being attacked. Guess what?
Run, man.
Okay? So, there are these two mindsets.
And what psychology have discovered is
they are mutually exclusive. It's either
one or the other.
The other thing that they discovered is
the altruistic mindset is what leads to
creativity.
Okay? Creativity.
Um and passion
and love.
Okay? The
And the utilitarian mindset is one
that's focused on rewards.
Okay? Like grades.
So, it is impossible
to both want to have really good grades
as well as help the world. But what's
interesting is Harvard wants that, okay?
So, in your application, you have to say
to Harvard,
I have a passion. I will die for my
passion. But at the same time, I want to
be a billionaire and I will die trying
to be a billionaire. At the same time, I
know it's important to be loyal to
Harvard, so I I will die being loyal to
Harvard, okay? The only people who can
do this people are people who have
dissociative personality disorder.
Okay?
And they can they can test for that in
the application. They're so experienced
that they know exactly
how you think, okay? They all Like come
on, guy. You would not apply to Harvard
if you were not if you were not
utilitarian, okay?
Right?
But you have to pretend you're not.
And that's what makes people crazy,
okay? Because you're basically an actor.
Harvard wants the best actors in the
world.
They want people to to go through life
pretending they're something they're
not, okay? They want Barack Obama. The
problem with Barack Obama is he's
soulless.
He stands for nothing.
Okay? In 2008, he promised people hope
and change.
The moment he gets in office, he's like,
"Sorry, man. I was just joking. Why did
you believe me?"
Okay? Then in 2012, when when it's time
for re-election,
he said, "Oh, you know what? I want hope
and change." Okay? Then 2016, he's like,
"You know what? Screw that. I'm I'm I'm
going to go water skiing now."
Okay? So, the man is actually soulless.
Stands for nothing.
All right?
Any more questions, guys?
Okay, great. So, thanks for today and uh
I'll see you guys after the break, okay?
So, we'll continue this after the break.